the only way to redemption is through
faith family and freedom and most of all
truth not lies
based on the Emotiv of your perceived
truth my truth no there is the truth the
idea that the left feeds you Taylor
Swift are people of realty they're not
going to help they don't help they don't
create they only destroy miss Americana
I watched it on Netflix last night and I
want to get into some details question
for you does it seem to you that that
Taylor Swift is a her woke 'no snow is
bad even by celebrity standards can you
think hard usually I actually feel sad I
watched this film and I felt really sad
for Taylor Swift and I want to know what
you thought when you watch this this is
clearly someone who just discovered any
woke ideology but any kind of an
ideology and assumes that nobody else
has known about this the fact is other
people have looked into this have
studied this have debated this for
decades and Taylor so if you just you
just didn't care
and so it really is kind of sad to see
someone who's been so misinformed who
now fancies himself the the arbiter of
truths and women's rights when you watch
this film and what really bothered me I
want to go through it it was kind of
entertaining film we'll get to the fact
that the person who made it is a
radically Pro 3rd trimester abortion
filmmaker most people don't know that
but what bothered me was there were so
many thoughtless answers that were
stated by Taylor Swift in the absolute
which is really indicative of someone
who's green and figuring out their
worldview which is somewhat scary
because this person has an unbelievable
uh sphere of influence so I think the
first clip we have is Taylor Swift if
I'm not mistaken her talking about
deprogramming internal misogyny good I'm
trying to be as educated as possible on
how to respect people on how to
deprogram the misogyny in my own brain
toss it out reject it and resist it like
there is no such thing as a [ __ ] there
is no such thing as a [ __ ]
yeah but what about someone who has sex
with a lot of different people for I
don't know let's say money or to advance
their career I'm not saying that about
Taylor Swift that really I don't think
Taylor Swift is a [ __ ] very much I want
to be clear but to say there's like it's
a figment of your mad
[Music]
you can't drop a corner without hitting
a [ __ ] a picture and ass it's sounds
really interesting there's no such thing
as a [ __ ] there's no such thing as a bit
but we don't apply that to men because
we also saw in this film where they
referred to men I don't know if she did
as pricks or as [ __ ] right or as
rubes and by the way I accept that some
guys are and some women are and I don't
mean that that defines them and their
entirety but some women sometimes can
act really bleep I mean sort of you know
[Laughter]
like Shakira's performance Leslie okay
so here's something else to her she was
talking about again another sort of
facet of locusts and you see this you
just in other words when you see her
making these statements you know the
blog that she just read you know okay I
thought that in the eighth grade too
when I had a feminist professor I got it
here's one where she talks about
apologizing sorry that was a real soap
why did I say sorry because it was
annoying I think she goes oh why did I
say shart ha I need to retrain myself
okay that's right yeah because men never
apologize it's true right that's just a
female think it's all people kid on the
idea she makes all these statements in
the absolute in the film in the absolute
in this film that women weren't always
trained to apologize well if you did
something wrong for example if one was
acting like a journalist maybe she says
she's sorry Rick
your words not mine maybe he needs to
say you're sorry but this idea that men
just walk through life without ever
having to apologize again some of these
opinions will change for Taylor Swift
notably on this that men don't apologize
once she gets married ever it's it's not
even this is my part-time job yes my
full-time gig is just apologizing well I
can see that all right and then that
here we go this is all you know it's all
sort of culminates in the film with her
talking about politics at length which
is you know something that's obviously
raised a few eyebrows because she didn't
use to be one of those people a nice
girl doesn't force their opinion
some people a nice girl smiles and waves
and says thank you a nice girl doesn't
make people feel uncomfortable with her
views yeah like a nice girl sure a nice
girl smiles sure a nice girl doesn't
deliberately make people feel
uncomfortable no but a nice girl can
also still have strong opinions and do
those things it doesn't have to be
either/or and by the way she talks about
this in the film she's you know I was
told to shut up about politics as a
woman well what do you think your male
country stars they were they were told
to be divisive about politics right you
think they're being coached on how to
cut their audience in half right exactly
please can someone Dixie Chicks me and
won over my John Deere it's that to you
because you're a woman and that's the
danger of someone who's coming into
politics very late hasn't thought about
these things critically has a huge
sphere of influence and decides to go
all right this is only happening because
I'm a woman
no no no you've just been blissfully
unaware of all these things for a very
long time good men don't want women to
experience most of the hardships that
are described by film anyway the eating
disorder we'll get into that I
understand that and I don't want that
for you and I think Taylor Swift is a
decent person I just think she's very
misguided and I don't think this is
something to celebrate I think of this
were a person who this were a person
writing a paper in your college class
you'd give it an F and say this is very
shallow but instead because it's a woman
saying I'm a woman getting my opinion
and if you judge me it's only because
I'm a woman everyone goes oh we have to
clap it's not really true and speaking
of which let's go to this next clip
which again makes me very sad and I'll
explain why in a little bit um is this
the one where Taylor Swift is talking
about by the way any defenses yet mm-hmm
her musics great I don't think this is
for lack of it I think that Taylor Swift
like most artists is a very sensitive
person probably a very empathetic person
and just completely misinformed but the
problem that I see is her putting on
armor were anyone anytime somebody says
well one second you may be wrong about
that idea it's your mansplaining anyone
who uses words like patriarchy or
mansplaining or trigger on ironically
doesn't know what they're talking about
let's go to the clip which is very said
Taylor Shep talking about and I
understand and I empathize with with her
not that I've gone through this myself
but I do know women who have
body image and female body image issues
there's always some standard of the
beauty that you're not meeting because
if you're fit enough then you don't have
that ass that everybody wants but if you
have enough weight on you to have an ass
then your stomach isn't flat enough it's
all just impossible any hearing a
portion that it's hard for your heart
not to go out to her by the way but
talking as though this is something that
we've talked applies to women like
female body issues like you know I just
can't let people judge women in the way
that that men aren't judged if you
haven't seen the film's is kind of an
ongoing theme well I know you know
that's not true
Taylor Swift how I looked at your dating
roster Taylor Lautner Zac Effron the
Jonas Brothers I don't know Virgo 3 or
not Jake Gyllenhaal Harry's sales you
don't live in a world where men don't
have six packs for you if a man is over
a buck fifty he's over the hill right
and something else I think is important
the eating disorder she talks about this
that's not because of the patriarchy or
I don't think that there were any
straight men out there who would say who
would have told you you know what I
think that Taylor Swift would be pretty
if she lost about 20 know if anything
most men would say I think she's cute
that she's a little thin a lot of guys
say that you know and I thought that
they were wrong I thought that she was
naturally thin having a mom who was
naturally thin and used to get shamed by
obese people that she wasn't a real
woman I thought it wasn't my place to
necessarily speak turns out it wasn't
nature it was her actually starving
herself but that was because of
magazines edited by gay entertainment
industry elitist and female fashion
icons not straight men here's actually
exercise that you could do
Taylor so what I'm hoping that actually
this if she does watch this because she
needs just you know not what you said
you were defending her you're just
attacking me and rightfully so I deserve
it
I don't pay nearly enough fun retainer
she walked into these rooms let's say
it's let's say it's the the Grammys or
whatever's of the VMAs or let's it's the
Met Gala okay Taylor so what I'm hoping
this is helpful and you actually listen
to this because I know you're glued to
your phone screen you've talked about
that in the film and you answer a lot to
critics on social media haters I believe
you call them and this is not what this
is I want you to look up any of the
scathing reviews of your outfits or your
appearance at most of these galas or
awards
where you maybe even made some of these
statements let's let's just take the Met
Gala I'm pretty sure you want to the Met
Gala find me a scathing review of your
outfit or appearance at the Met Gala
written by a straight male you won't you
won't guarantee you walk into that room
at the VMAs the only [ __ ] who are going
she's wearing that guess what it's not
the strike he's going I'd have sex with
it and then there goes another one I'd
have sex with that too we're not that
hard to please and you're a very pretty
woman every man would say so that's why
they wouldn't repeatedly ask they vote
you as sexiest one of the sexiest women
in the world in all your splendor
whether you're skinnier whether you're
thicker so I want you to just understand
sort of the object of your ire here's it
shouldn't be the villains who you're
making that it's not straight white men
it's the people in your industry and
that's why you feel hollow and life may
be as devoid of meaning I really hope
that someone around you helps you learn
this and process this let's go on to the
next point where I think she's if I'm
not mistaken discussing and in rifles
the ideas sort of rape culture so she
starts off correct and I do empathize
with her I'm so glad she won this court
case but then she makes another
statement in the absolute that is
factually incorrect this picture shows
the moment Muller inappropriately
grabbed her putting his hand up her
skirt judges this had happened to me we
told his boss they did an investigation
he got fired
then he sued me for millions of dollars
so I counter sued for $1 something is
different in my life completely and
unchangeably different senses the sexual
assualt trial last year like it
no no and in my organization or if my
family will ever understand what that
was like well a second again I
understand that I'm glad that she won
you can see that book sure it's great
it's clear as day no men have a problem
with women coming forward especially if
there's evidence and we often believe
women in the absence of evidence we're
just saying that that shouldn't be the
system of law that we have people still
need to be innocent until proven guilty
but no man in your organization or
family will ever know no men get groped
no men get sexually assaulted till at
the Terry Cruiser tell that to the men
who make up the overwhelming statistic
of rapes that occurred men get raped
more often if you have a prison rape but
I know some people say well we shouldn't
include prison rape well you should
because men get sentenced and put in
prison for the same crimes with more
harsh sentencing than women so it should
be relevant
someone did we go what about Terry Crews
so I understand your point yes women do
need to be protected that's the man
splinting that's me being patronizing
and rightfully so if I were your husband
if I were your your brother your father
or as I am with my wife I am incredibly
protective because I understand that as
a woman she is more physically
vulnerable than a man that's how
straight men think but then to use that
in springboard into a false absolute
statement that no man could ever know no
that's incorrect and it shows that you
have a blind spot as to I guess the
people with whom you might sort of find
yourself empathetic and now this brings
us to something more where she gets so
out of her element and I believe this
was a race in Tennessee as a Blackburn I
then this is where she came out and
actually campaigned for the first time
or or I don't even know if she endorsed
a candidate officially but I know she
anti endorse who condemn not yeah
Blackburn the other Wow and tossed her
hat in the ring let's watch this she
thinks that if you're a gay couple or
even if you look like a gay couple you
should be a lot of things Marcia
Blackburn in a restaurant really basic
human rights and it's bright and wrong
at this point and I can't see another
commercial and see her disguising these
policies behind the words Tennessee
Christian values
those aren't Tennessee Christian values
if I get bad press for saying don't put
a homophobic racist in office then I get
bad press for that and she goes on to
say that Marsha Blackburn that doesn't
represent a single
women's issue huh there are no women who
are pro-life what if you're wrong what
if what if Donald Trump isn't a
homophobic racist what if the finalists
in Celebrity Apprentice were Cyndi
Lauper and Arsenio Hall what of this is
a guy who has a long and storied history
of employing and working with members of
the LGBTQ AE IP in a silent number - and
has had a long history of working
alongside black people in New York City
so what if you're wrong about that again
so many false statements so many
assumptions and this is just someone who
is shallow
who hasn't examined who who kind of
froze in time they talked about this I
think even tellers you have talked about
this in the film they freeze in time
basically they only reached the maturity
that they reached before they became
famous but now think she has the inside
track and what I'm saying
Taylor is is you don't you don't at all
and you're looking for happiness in all
the wrong places and now this whole idea
of your truth will its base them in a
mode of response not on fact right and I
don't want you to take this as a
criticism against your womanhood it's
not that at all I want you to become the
woman who I think you can be and it can
be a formidable woman not that you
already aren't you you are right now but
you know you've back slid she was
shocked by the way when Blackburn still
won
and then I I believe this was yeah after
she had tweeted and instagrammed against
Blackburn fifty thousand new people
registered to vote in Blackburn still
won I can't believe it I can't believe
it I can't believe it she gets to be
protectors before female senator in
Tennessee if she's that she's from in a
wig
she represents no female interests
that's where was it no female interests
none what about the babies who aren't
killed it could take it just as easily
be represented by governor Ralph Northam
right I'm not talking about blackface
I'm talking about abortion up until
birth a lot of scandals though both of
that not quite Trudeau but what he's
getting there
yes but III think that you know I don't
want to put words in to any woman's
mouth but the idea that the that the
economy is not a woman's issue right
right yeah it's not a why are women
limited to these certain topics just
because Taylor privacy yeah yeah any of
those issues I mean those that that in
and of itself is again back to that
issue that she's not really diving to
the into what these problems are and how
they affect people who aren't flying
around in ten million dollar private jet
well not only and let's remove the
private jet think Estelle and I
understand the point it is a valid point
but everyone's a hypocrite but here
let's scale it back okay private jet I
understand your jet setting you're going
to tours all across the world right
you're going to Europe and you're going
to South America fine you don't have to
be in a ship in it in the longest
suburban edition you can find the entire
film by the way would it be and by the
way you don't have to have basically
infantryman an entire cavalcade of
security as you do well you know what
how about it's a women's issue because
other women out there want a party that
allows them to drive a safer larger SUV
and since they can't afford security
they believe it's their issue as a woman
to be able to protect their family their
own bodies was a firearm and their
god-given right to self-preservation is
that a woman's issue because maybe you
have a blind spot here because you have
so many people serving and rightfully so
you're unbelievably talented but how was
that not a woman's issue maybe these
women not only know more than you maybe
they have more life experience than you
and this is something that's important
to 50 thousand new people registered to
vote here's the thing more people
registered because you sent out an
Instagram message and a tweet may sound
sort of an Instagram message a post I
get it that message to 200 million
people but but at the point that I'm
making here's maybe people heard that
and they'd like you in spite of your
uninformed politics yeah and they
decided against you try
to basically affect a race where let's
be honest you don't live in Tennessee
anymore you spend more time in New York
you've talked about that at least up
until recently right so maybe people do
know about this and you're not opening
their eyes their eyes are open and maybe
some of them are saying she's so out of
touch she just doesn't understand why
would support Blackburn over a party
that believes in abortion up until birth
and open borders and taken away my right
to protect myself she maybe doesn't know
that because of her armed security
detail 24/7 and the fact that she gets
carted around in Yukon Denalis well god
bless her home god bless her soul but
voting for the other guy her as much as
it is the industry that has created her
transformed her and ultimately will ruin
her but we'll get back to that this is
where she was talking about President
Donald Trump and they asked President
Donald Trump about Taylor Swift
endorsing anyone not named Trump I think
his answer was about as friendly as you
can get but here you go let's say that I
like Taylor's music about 25% less now
I'll give you this what 25% 50% because
she's liberal birds like you picked 25%
because he was thinking I've got four of
them in the Air Force one disc changer
but there's no way I can get rid of they
can only use discs that's why I have a
95 compact disc changer I don't use mp3s
they could track you folks that in
contrails so I did like that couldn't be
and they tried to make a big thing about
this in the film that was funny couldn't
be a guy who's being a little bit more
she has some family members who like
Taylor Swift because it was positively
mild yes yeah thank the Lord above it
you don't have a nickname Taylor Swift I
know right
but she said worse things about Trump
and he said that that's not even care
what is kidding out of the math about
beta right of course I know we do have
to get we're gonna get to life advice
here no half-asian bill will have to go
but something else did a lot of people
don't realize
when you watch this film and a little
kind of subtle things all of the people
criticizing Taylor Swift the vast
majority of them are Fox News they don't
show the MSNBC yeah and the VMA and the
the E Hollywood who are these are the
people who criticize her most in a most
shallow fashion if you go to Fox News
they might be saying like oh I don't
think she should be talking about
politics but they just it's just sort of
a bait and switch that they pull a lot
it's a sleight of hand the film director
I believe her name is Lana is it Lana
Wilson Lana Wilson I don't know I looked
and she actually directed the film after
tiller promoting third trimester
abortion clinics by the way Wow let's be
really clear I couldn't watch all of it
and let me end it with this if let's
just let me assume that Taylor Swift or
some of her fans might be watching this
and I'm by the way I understand that
Taylor Swift fans are more respectful in
the fans of Cher I am respectful the
cher fans it's just a bunch of angry gay
pride floats with people they're topping
off just to show you their cher wall and
try to Docs you I have never seen more
more vehement fans than sheer fans it's
great oh my gays love Cher it must be
the pageantry it is oh yes I got off
track but we'll have a bone to pick with
cher fans I respect someone like Taylor
Swift the respect for being vulnerable
particularly in a film like this about
about your issues like eating disorder
she talks about or any time people come
out and they're they're vulnerable about
things like depression or mental health
right people talk about that a lot but I
want people to know this and this is why
I thought that this was important to
talk about I talked about that on this
show I've talked about struggling with
mental health issues I've talked about
you know not feeling very good about
myself getting bullied in high school
and the reason I do that is because I
want everyone out there I want you in
someone like Taylor Swift I want you to
know that the left doesn't have a
monopoly on empathy or on the idea of
dealing with mental health or hardships
again I have been depressed I know what
it's like for it to feel bleak or for
you to feel suicidal for you to feel
like there's nothing going on you know I
know what it's like to wake up and feel
the hopelessness of not wanting to face
the day and and this is why I talk about
all of the issues that we talk about in
the show because the only way to
redemption is through faith family and
freedom and in most of all truth not
lies
based on the Emotiv of you
or perceived truth my truth no there is
the truth and I'm here to tell you
people like Taylor Swift because it's
not just tell there are people out there
and we saw this we saw it with David
Hogg we saw it with them we're gonna see
with Greta Sundberg they chew up child
stars and spit them out yeah okay I mean
I tell you the idea that the left feeds
you Taylor Swift are people of your ilk
they're not going to help they don't
help they don't create they only destroy
they only kill and Taylor Swift you're
experiencing this right now this is
what's so sad for me when I watch this
video
you were unhappy okay because of the
lies you embrace not from Christian
conservatism but from progressive
feminists talking points women in
Taylors what you're finding is that you
will not find self-worth in a career or
independence from men anymore than
you'll find self-worth in that perfect
bikini body into any minority groups or
marginalized women are men or men out
there for that matter I guarantee you
okay this is what's important I
guarantee you that if every single wall
of systemic oppression both real or
imagined were to come crumbling down
tomorrow it wouldn't make you any
happier it wouldn't make you any more
fulfilled
look I don't espouse the ideas and
values of Christ of conservatism of
traditionalism because I don't empathize
with the downtrodden the sadder or the
misfits the broken of spirit I espouse
them because I do I espouse them because
I am you because I was that you can be
depressed you can be a weirdo you can be
a freak you can bring a free spirit and
still find redemption in the truth and
as hard as that may be to swallow you do
need to recognize the fact that you can
live your truth but at some point it is
going to come to a screeching halt when
you go face-first into the brick wall
that is the truth and I just hope that
people like Taylor Swift and people who
follow her out there I hope that you
realize this before all of a sudden you
hit that brick wall and you're looking
around wondering where all your friends
went to because they're not going to be
there
guess who I am I'm Josh Hartnett bet you
didn't think you'd see that face in a
while this is what we call an end card
which is where I tell you that you
should subscribe if you like this video
or click one of these other videos that
you may like hit the notification bell
of course join mug club because that's
what allows us to continue doing these
videos and just so you know youtube
actually is created a new policy where
they might start outright banning
channels that are no longer commercially
viable which means that this is merely a
figment of your imagination